aber wir gehen jetzt rein ins plenum in
den deutschen minister die fraktion die
linke einen entschließungsantrag
eingebracht über den wir am freitag nach
der schlussabstimmung abstimmen werden
nach einer interfraktionellen
vereinbarung sind für die aussprache zu
diesem einzeltäter 224 minuten
vorgesehen
da wir das gleich vermutlich beschließen
werden verbinde ich es gleich mit dem
hinweis dass es auch schön wäre wenn wir
uns dann an diese getroffene
beschlussfassung hielten weil dies ja
wiederum folgerungen für den weiteren
ablauf der pläne beratungen am
nachmittag und abend hat sind sie mit
dieser vereinbarung einverstanden das
ist offenkundig der fall dann haben wir
das so beschlossen
ich eröffne die aussprache und erteile
das wort dem kollegen gregor gysi für
die fraktion die linke
einen schönen guten morgen lieber
präsident meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren lassen sie mich zu beginn etwas
zum haushalt sagen ich muss ihnen sagen
herr schäuble dann als sie wissen auch
dass allgemein über politik geredet wird
und damit abgerechnet wird das ist ja
auch unser gutes recht aber zum haushalt
muss ich ihnen folgendes sagen bisher
bundesfinanzminister galten sie als
jemand der immer versucht er
einigermaßen seriös die zahlen
rüberzubringen und diesmal nein nein
diesmal sind sie einen anderen weg
gegangen
sie hatten vorab gekündigt die
neuverschuldung in diesem jahr wird 65
milliarden betragen
und sie haben vorab verkündet im
nächsten jahr gibt's einen
ausgeglichenen haushalt und jetzt
richten sie ihre ganze politik nur
danach der presse nicht einzugestehen
dass sie sich geirrt
ich sage hier zwei beispiele entgegen
dem sachverständigenrat haben sie die
steuereinnahmen einfach um 1 5
milliarden euro erhöht nur um bei 65
milliarden neuverschuldung zu bleiben
und entgegen allen aussagen haben sie
die schuldenbelastung einfach um 1 2
milliarden gesenkt und um zum ausgleich
haushalt nächstes jahr zu kommen
machen sie zwei dinge sie verschieben
die kindergelderhöhung sein können uns
jetzt nicht leisten dass krieg kann
ausgeglichen haushalt muss verschoben
werden
sie verschieben die abschaffung der
kalten progression
um zu erklären dass heißt es die brutto
vielleicht drei prozent mehr netto den
halben prozent mehr
das nennt man kalte progression sollte
auch beseitigt werden lassen sie auch
ausfallen und sie reduzieren die
öffentlichen investitionen in diesem
jahr nur 29,8 milliarden betragen
im nächsten jahr 24 7 milliarden wissen
sie was das bedeutet das bedeutet dass
straßen brücken schulen schwimmbäder
kultureinrichtungen netze dort marode
bleiben wo sie
marode sind weil die mittel fehlen die
wir dringend für investitionen benötigt
dringend bei der krankenversicherung
versichern herr schäuble in den beiden
jahren kürzen sie die öffentlichen
investitionen um sechs milliarden euro
was das ergebnis können wir uns alle
ausrechnet sie haben nämlich eine neue
regelung geschaffen ja auch die spd dass
künftig die beiträge nur noch von den
versicherten erhöht werden können und
nicht nur die beiträge der unternehmen
sie heben die paritätische finanzierung
auch und die krankenkassen haben jetzt
schon angekündigt dass sie die beiträge
für die versicherten erhöhen werden das
ist das ergebnis und das machen sie
alles mit herr gabriel
das machen sie mit oppermann als latent
schäuble zu sagen da musst du dich im
halb korrigieren was den peitschen satz
gesagt nein sie spielen und einfach zu
das ist alles verschoben werden auch sie
dürften das nicht zulassen
also ich will mir heute ersparen zum
affentheater bei der eeg-umlage etwas zu
sagen also was sie dargebotene 200
seiten änderungsanträge innerhalb von
zwei stunden
dass es abenteuerlich aber darüber
werden wir uns einmal unterhalten lassen
nämlich etwas zur hand
also jetzt haben wir einen fortschritt
in rente immerhin haben sie ja
festgelegt dass bei 45 beitragsjahre hat
darf zwei jahre früher in rente gehen
als die anderen aber sie ändern doch an
der grundsätzlich falschen entscheidung
nicht die demographie zur grundlage zu
geben ihre aussage von allen anderen
parteien lautet da die gesellschaft
immer älter wird muss man immer länger
arbeiten und immer später seine rente
beziehen
glauben sie wirklich dass das eine
lösung ist könnte es nicht sein dass wir
unseren beruf mit dem beruf anderer
verwechseln vielleicht kann man ja mit
90 jahren im bundestag noch rum dürfen
ohne dass es einer nackt aber sie können
kein dach mehr decken mid 90s müssen sie
endlich begreifen
ich sage ich und ich sagen wir hatten
mal eine andere bundesrepublik
deutschland da war der entscheidende
faktor die produktivitätsentwicklung und
so wie sich die produktivität
entwickelte entwickelte sich auch die
löhne und so wie sich die löhne
entwickelten entwickelten sich auch die
rente und dann kommt man zu einer rente
die eine funktion hat dass man den
lebensstandard den man sich im
erwerbsleben erarbeitet hat
aufrechterhalten und fortsetzen kann
und davon sind wir inzwischen deutlich
entfernt und was müssen wir tun
wir müssen wir alte rentenformel wieder
einführen dann werden sie sagen die
bezahlen
ganz einfach indem wir in der neuen
generation sagen alle mit
erwerbseinkommen müssen in die
gesetzliche rentenversicherung einzahlen
auch bundestagsabgeordnete auch
beamtinnen und beamte auch rechtsanwälte
alle müssen ja ich wusste dass ihr
argument kommt dass die auch ansprüche
haben und deshalb sage ich ihnen müssten
wir ja es geht noch weiter wir müssen
die beitragsbemessungsgrenzen abschaffen
die willkürlichen verkürzen millionen
verdient muss sein in seinen bald 92
millionen pizza und jetzt warten sie
dann nicht sie können nicht mehr zu
hören das ist doch das mindeste den
wechsel und jetzt kommt mein dritter
vorschlag und die rentenerhöhung für die
spitzenverdiener wird abgeflacht
das erlaubt das bundesverfassungsgericht
und dann brauchen wir über altersarmut
überhaupt nicht mehr zu reden weil alles
bezahlt wäre
große koalition müsste doch mal zu einer
solch großen rekord pc aber können wir
alles vergessen findet nicht dadurch
findet nicht statt und jetzt sage ich
ihnen noch eins im vierundzwanzigster
jahr der deutschen einheit immer noch
nicht die gleiche rente für die gleiche
lebensleistung in ost und west zu zahlen
ist ein skandal
ich hatte wort das sie dass wenigstens
mal weg und sage ich was für mütter
rente oder habe ich drei fragen frau
bundeskanzler
die habe ich an sie die habe ich auch an
ihren vizekanzler an gabriel und ihr
habe ich auch an sie herr
fraktionsvorsitzender kauder drei fragen
die erste frage warum bekommt man für
ein kind das vor 1992 geboren wurde nach
wie vor einen geringeren renten zuschlag
als für ein kind das ab 1992 geboren
wurde war es wirklich so viel leichter
kinder vor 92 aufzuziehen als danach
erklären dass bitte der bevölkerung ich
verstehe es nicht
eine zweite frage warum ist ein ost kind
für sie im 24 jahr der deutschen
einheiten immer noch weniger wert als
ein weste erklären sie mir dass meine
dritte frage da die mittler rente aus
den beiträgen zur rentenversicherung
bezahlt wird bedeutet das folgendes die
wie die kassiererin zahlt beiträge zur
rentenversicherung mithin auch die
mütter rente der bäckermeister hat
lohnnebenkosten zahlt auch beiträge in
der gesetzlichen rentenversicherung
bezahlt auch die mutter nennt es gibt
aber ein problem sie frau
bundeskanzlerin sie ihre gabriel
sie herr kauder und ich bezahlen gemüter
rente nicht denn wir dürfen ja gar keine
beiträge in die gesetzliche
rentenversicherung bezahlen
kinder ja es gibt aber keine erhöhten
steuerzuschuss sie erhöhen die mütter
rennt und machen keinen erhöhten
steuerzuschuss ich komme gleich dazu
kinder die man zur welt bringt ändern an
beiträgen gar nichts diese kinder sind
eine leistung für die familie und die
gesellschaft wenn die mütter rente
steuerfinanziert wäre dann müssten wir
vier also die bundeskanzlerin sie herr
kauder herr gabriel und ich deutlich
mehr bezahlen für die mütter rente als
die lidl kassiererin das wäre gerecht
sie aber sorgen dafür dass es nur die
deg kassierte und nur der bäckermeister
bezahlt und wir nicht deshalb lade sie
ein sagen sie ein paar gabriel unter
kauder ist lade sie ein wir besuchen zu
dritt sie herr kauder sieger gabriel und
ich eine lidl kassiererin und der
erklären sie dann warum sie die mütter
rente bezahlen muss und wir drei nicht
ich kann es nicht sieben hörigen aber
gerne dabei zu bei dieser erklärung
ich sage ich nicht dass es so etwas
wurden grob ungerecht hören sie auch
diese versicherungsfremden leistungen
müssen durch steuern und nichts anderes
finanziert werden dafür müssen wirklich
top
jetzt komme ich zum mindestlohn ich
freue mich dass sie sich aufregen als
wahrscheinlich doch die schwarze zu
treffen
also wir kommen ja zumindest wird der
soll ja flächendeckend und gesetzlich
sein und ich sage ihnen jetzt ganz klar
es wird höchste zeit dass er kommt ich
begrüße dass unsere partei hat dafür zu
einer zeit gekämpft als alle anderen
parteien noch dagegen war und ich freue
mich dass wir jetzt endlich in
deutschland erleben dass wir eine art
flächendeckenden gesetzlichen
mindestlohn mutter aber liebe spd wiebe
grünen lieber dgb 8 50 euro habt ihr als
mindestlohn schon vor jahren gefordert
ist euch gar nicht aufgefallen dass das
leben inzwischen etwas teurer geworden
ist dass man das vielleicht anpassen
müsste
deshalb sage ich ihn ja unsere forderung
nach zehn euro brutto und nicht erst
eine anpassung 2018 sondern in einem
jahr
das wäre eigentlich die
selbstverständlichkeit die wir dringend
benötigen um ein leben in würde förmlich
sprechen herr plech entdeckt und deshalb
sage ich ihnen flächendeckend heißt es
darf keine ausnahmen geben und sie
machen zwei ausnahmen die mich zwei
wesentliche ausnahmen die erste ist sie
sagen jugendliche unter 18 jahren haben
keinen anspruch auf den gesetzlichen
mindestlohn und das begründen sie damit
dass wenn die zu viel verdienen sind die
nicht mehr an ausbildung interessiert
dann lernen die nicht sondern gehen
gleich arbeiten mit anderen worten sie
meinen jugendliche sind doof wir meinen
dass nicht alle jugendlichen wissen
wenn sie gut ausgebildet sind haben sie
später ganz andere zukunftschancen auch
ganz andere verdienstmöglichkeiten
behandeln sie doch die jugendlichen
nicht als dorf und auch nur
grundgesetzwidrig wie wollen sie denn
begründen dass ein 17-jähriger für die
gleiche arbeit weniger verdient als ein
18-jähriger das ist überhaupt nicht
hinzunehmen ist überhaupt nicht hinzu
kommt eine zweite brücke
was sind die langzeitarbeitslosen bei
den langzeitarbeitslosen sich ein halbes
jahr sagen sie haben sie keinen anspruch
auf den gesetzlichen mindestlohn
wissen sie was das bedeutet sie sagen
einem langzeitarbeitslosen er ist uns
der gesellschaft nicht einmal der
gesetzliche mindestlohn wert das ist
demütigend bitte sprechen sie das das
ist dem das ist ein mensch dessen würde
zu acht lassen
immerhin das bundesamt für statistik hat
jetzt veröffentlicht das 20 2 prozent
unserer beschäftigten weniger als 850
euro verdienen es wird also höchste zeit
dass wenigstens das passiert weil sie
sagen muss noch mal zehn euro wären
angemessen und dann noch etwas das
statistische bundesamt frau
bundeskanzlerin hat jetzt veröffentlicht
das acht millionen unserer bürgerinnen
und bürger 8 millionen nicht einmal
jeden zweiten tag eine vollwertige
mahlzeit genießen will
das ist eine armut die sich ein so
reiches land wie deutschland niemals
leisten niemals weiß da das ist
grundgesetzwidrig
aber ich muss noch auf etwas hinweisen
wenn wir den flächendeckenden
gesetzlichen mindestlohn selbst wenn mit
krücken und ausnahmen irgendwie bekommen
dann führt das natürlich zu einer
allgemeinen lohne gehaltssteigerung sie
müssen ja von folgendem ausgehen einer
verdient heute sechs der nächste sieben
der nächsten acht der nächsten euro und
da werden die untereinander sagen ja ich
kann nicht flüssig wie alle 850 euro
verdienen oder nur 50 cent mehr
ich mache eine qualifizierte tätigkeit
also muss ja auch mein lohn angehoben
werden das führt zu einer allgemein lohn
und gehaltssteigerung die wir übrigens
auch dringend verdienen binnenwirtschaft
benötigen unsere abhängigkeit vom
außenhandel kann auch zu einem
verhängnis werden wenn sich nämlich die
situation in anderen ländern ändern
deshalb müssen wir die binnenwirtschaft
stärken und das geht nur über
investitionen herr bundesfinanzminister
und ich über den abbau von investitionen
und es geht nur um über die stärkung der
kaufkraft das heißt höhere renten höhere
löhne und gehälter und höhere
sozialleistungen
aber ich sage dass wir auch deutlich
damit
hier nicht hinterher sagen die tat es
nicht gesagt natürlich weiß ich dass die
preise bei handwerksleistungen
aufsteigen werden weil sich die
friseurmeisterin und der bäckermeister
anders den mindestlohn zum teil gar
nicht leisten kann
aber dann können wir es auch verkraften
wenn wir eine allgemeine lohn und
gehaltssteigerung lassen sie mich etwas
zur bildung sagen also das ist für mich
auch ein leidenschaft thema ich kenne
niemanden im bundestag der sagen wird er
ist dagegen dass für chancengleichheit
in der bildung kam für die kinder kennen
die man das sein wird
aber die ganze organisation die ganze
struktur schließt eine chancengleichheit
aus die soziale stellung der eltern
setzt sich in der bildung der kinder
fort und dagegen unternimmt die
regierung gar nicht dass es ein wirklich
schwer wiegender formel was brauchen wir
brauchen ein flächendeckendes netz an
ganztägigen kindertagesstätten
einrichtungen und gemeinschaftsschulen
mit einem gesunden vollwertigen
mittagessen und alles gebührenfrei darin
müssen wir investieren und dann brauchen
wir
ja ich weiß da sagen sie mir dass das da
sagen sie mir dass das so teuer ist aber
für die commerzbank da haben sie
hunderte milliarden euro aber nicht für
ein gesundes essen für die kinder in den
schulen kindertagesstätten es ja nicht
hingehen meistert und dann brauchen wir
gut ausgebildete und gut bezahlte
erzieherinnen und erzieher in den
kindertagesstätten gut ausgebildete und
gut bezahlte lehrerinnen und lehrer in
den schulen
wir brauchen kleinere klassen frequenzen
begreifen sie doch endlich ihre chance
in deutschland preisbildung unsere gold
und erdöl vorkommen können sie vergessen
unsere souza heißt bildung daran müssen
wir investieren
natürlich brauchen wir auch eine bessere
förderung der berufsausbildung und der
hochschulausbildung und wir müssen das
kooperationsverbot für bundesländer für
die schulen überwinden ich bitte sie
wir haben 16 bundesländer und deshalb 16
verschiedene schulsysteme
ich bestreite ja nicht dass das ein
großer fortschritt im neunzehnten
jahrhundert war aber mit dem 21
jahrhundert hat das nun überhaupt nichts
mehr zu tun
egal wo kinder in deutschland leben sie
müssen eine chance auf eine top bildung
und ausbildung haben von mecklenburg
vorpommern bis bayern
dafür müssen wir endlich soll und dessen
herr schäuble ist die von ihnen eben
so wie kürzlich vorgenommene kürzung der
ausgaben für bildung um 500 millionen
euro
indiskutabel also ich sage ihnen
wirklich leisten sie einen beitrag für
die chancengleichheit der kinder in der
bildung das wäre ein ganz wichtiges
signal und unserer gesellschaft bekomme
ich zu den steuern
es gibt ja jetzt ein steuer berichtigen
kommission lesen sie den mann kader da
steht hinsichtlich deutschland folgendes
drin
ja richtig muss es ihnen ja sagen weil
sie es ja nicht von alleine lesen muss
dass hier alles nachholen was sehen sie
aber die zeit ist immer so kurz also die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer und
die gesamte mittelschicht sagt der
eu-bericht in deutschland wird viel zu
hoch besteuert und der eu bericht sagt
die bezieherinnen und bezieher von
kapitaleinkünften insbesondere von hohen
kapitaleinkünften werden viel zu niedrig
besteuert
es gibt einen interessanten vergleich
die steuern auf löhne und gehälter in
deutschland machen 56 6 prozent des
gesamten steueraufkommens aus der eu
durchschnitt liegt nur bei 51 prozent
und die steuern auf die kapitaleinkünfte
machen beim gesamten steueraufkommen in
deutschland 16 prozent aus im eu
durchschnitt aber 20 8 prozent daran
merken sie was passiert
die dollar millionäre haben zugenommen
um 14 prozent
die dollar dollar millionäre weltweit
besitzen ein vermögen von 40 millionen
euro das sind zwei drittel der welt
wirtschaftskraft und auch in deutschland
haben wir einen anstieg
die dollar millionäre haben zugenommen
von 980.000 auf 1,1 millionen
weltweit hat deutschland die
drittmeisten millionen wetter die
drittmeisten auf platz eins liegen die
usa auf platz zwei das wird einige
erstaunen china und auf platz drei liegt
deutschland ich darf nur erwähnen dass
die usa in china ein paar einwohner mehr
haben als deutschland trotzdem nehmen
wir platz drei ein
und sie weigern sich einen halben euro
mehr in der eu und in deutschland von
den millionären zu verlangen sie sagen
im ernst der friseurin in athen
sie hat das ganze zu finanzieren das ist
absurd was hier läuft wirklich absurd
sie war bei jedem schritt zu mehr
steuergerechtigkeit keine senkung keine
erhöhung kalte progression habe ich
schon gesagt verschoben aber dann gibt
es ja noch etwas den steuerbar nie
vergessen unsere einkommensteuer
verläuft nicht so die hat ihr sohn
braucht das ist die mitte der
gesellschaft die alles bezahlen
der finanziell untere teil kann es nicht
und an die reichen trauen sie sich nicht
ran
und deshalb muss die mitte der
gesellschaft alles bezahlen es gibt nur
eine partei im bundestag
sie fordert den steuer bauch zu
streichen das ist die linke die mittel
der gesellschaft wird nur von der linken
vertreten wissen wahrheit
meine bitte ein schritt könnten sie doch
wagen behandeln sie doch endlich
kapitaleinkünfte und arbeits einkünfte
wenigstens gleich das wäre ein
gewaltiger schock
wenigstens klar so komme ich zur außen-
und sicherheitspolitik frau
bundeskanzlerin alle kriege der letzten
jahre haben die menschheitsprobleme
nicht gelöst sondern verschärft ganz
egal ob ich an afghanistan denke ob ich
an den irak denke ob ich an libyen denke
was sagt unser bundespräsident wir
sollen noch mehr an militäreinsätzen
teilnehmen das bedeutet aber nicht wie
er meint mehr verantwortung das bedeutet
mehr verantwortung versagen das sage ich
ihnen ganz klar und der eigentliche
skandal in deutschland
der eigentliche skandal in deutschland
ist dass deutschland der drittgrößte
waffenexporteur weltweites wir verdienen
an jedem krieg hätte unser schluss aus
dem zweiten weltkrieg nicht lauten
müssen dass wir nie wieder an kriegen
verdienen wollen ich glaube das wäre das
mindeste gewesen und jetzt haben wir ab
als bundeskanzlerin dass sie im jahre
2008 panzer und auch noch eine
panzerfabrik also die lizenz zum
herstellen deutscher panzer an algerien
verkaufte und ich sage ihnen was haben
wir denn für zustände neige geht ist
kein demokratisches land und woher
wollen sie eigentlich wissen welche
zustände in algerien in fünf jahren
herrschen woher wollen wir eigentlich
wissen wer dann dort panzer für welche
zwecke herstellen das ist doch wahnsinn
und sie herr gabriel sahen nur verträge
sind einzuhalten haben sie denn
wenigstens mal geprüft ob man aussteigen
kann
aus diesem wahnsinnigen vertrag und
diese verantwortungslosigkeit überwinden
kann und wo bleibt denn wenigstens ihr
satz dass es solche verträge nie wieder
geben wird das wäre doch wohl das
mindeste
ich sage deutschland liefert waffen an
saudi arabien katar an den nato-partner
türkei
was erfahren wir jetzt die al qaida
terror armee hieß es
robert immer mehr territorien im irak
und in syrien carey der amerikanische
außenminister reist jetzt durch den
nahen osten versucht das irgendwie
aufzuhalten
aber wer hat denn diese armee bezahlt
die bezahlung kamen aus saudi-arabien
und katar und was hat die türkei gemacht
die hat diese kämpfenden terroristen mit
waffen ohne jede beanstandung durch die
türkei durchziehen lassen nach syrien
und irak das sind unsere partner und was
machen sie da ging fast nichts und jetzt
haben wir heute gelesen dass dieses
armee sogar kinder tötet ich sage ihnen
die konrad-adenauer-stiftung sagt
plötzlich man hätte assad in syrien
unterstützen müssen wo leben wir hier
eigentlich die zeiten werden immer
besser merken sie denn nicht dass diese
ganze außenpolitik patches weg von
waffenexporten hin zu einer friedlichen
konfliktlösung das muss die aufgabe der
bundesregierung sein nichts anderes
nun komme ich zur ukraine jetzt gibt es
ja gewisse fortschritte
eine power feuerpause durch präsident
poroschenko die rücknahme des
beschlusses der föderation versammlung
in moskau bis nach russland in die
ukraine einmarschieren darf auch sehr
wichtig und ich sage ihnen jetzt müssen
die europäische union und die nato
endlich wirkliche de eskalationsschritte
gehen hören sie auf mit den sanktionen
und mit der androhung von sanktionen
übrigens diese sanktionen wenn sie
wirklich kennen die
wirtschaftssanktionen treffen ja nicht
die usa die sie immer vorschlagen
sondern die antworten treffen dann uns
und die wirtschaft wir schützen in
diesem falle auch die wirtschaft das hat
sie nicht verdient
das sage ich ihnen klipp und klar ich
muss mich von göring eckardt sie haben
ja hier dazu gesprochen und sie haben
sich mit sahra wagenknecht
auseinandergesetzt und haben dann gesagt
wer die neue regierung oder wenn die
regierung nicht unterstütze oder die
politik nicht unterstütze der
unterstützt nicht die demokratisierung
der ukraine
wie soll ich das verstehen wir sind doch
schon gemeinsam gegen nazis aufgetreten
warum kritisieren sie nicht ebenso
scharf wie wir die mitgliedschaft von
faschistischen politiker in der
ukrainischen regierung und wissen sie
ich sag ihnen auch was die belgische
regierung dazu sagt ist das eine
wir haben eine andere geschichte und ich
finde der gesamte deutsche bundestag und
die gesamte deutsche regierung müsste
der ukrainischen regierung sagen bevor
wir euch helfen entlastet die
faschistischen minister aus ihren reihen
das wäre doch mal das mindeste
es wäre das mindeste der züricher immer
wieder bei der präsidentenwahl hätten
die so wenig stimmen bekommen umso
besser
was gibt es denn für einen grund die
nicht zu entlassen dann können wir den
druck sogar noch erhöhen und das zweite
haben sie zweifel lässt dass faschisten
sind
ich habe ihn ja den vorsitzenden der
partei jetzt die tiere sich wiederhole
das heute nicht aber eins sage ich ihnen
die hatten ein institut die svoboda
partei hat einen institut und das
institut trug den namen lose doppelt bis
zum jahr 2040 jetzt haben sie es
umbenannt
wegen des drucks von außen aber sie
trugen sie trug dieses institut trug den
namen joseph goebbels
das hat sich noch keine rechtsnationale
partei nach der nazi diktatur in europa
getraut nur bei svoboda partei und da
verlangen sie von uns dass ihr tattoo
nizza ist doch grotesk
ich kann das nicht dulden ich kann das
nicht und ich bin da alles andere ist
auch unverantwortlich und im kalten
krieg war der gewinner der westen er
zeigte allerdings keine bereitschaft auf
zu hören zu sehen
im kalten krieg gab es einflusssphären
der usa und einflusssphären der
sowjetunion aber die geld nicht mehr
kann man sagen sag' ich auch glücklicher
weise das problem ist nur die usa und
russland haben keine neue regeln
vereinbart
sie haben einfluss verloren beide
versuchen den vorhandenen zu sichern und
auch wieder auszubauen und kommen sich
dabei in die quere
in georgien in syrien in der ukraine
was gibt es für ein weg für neue
spielregeln nur ein
das völkerrecht der voller respekt vor
dem völkerrecht und die ersten die das
völkerrecht über bord geworfen haben
beim jugoslawien krieg war der westen
weil sie sich dafür nicht mehr
interessiert haben weil sie gesagt haben
wir sind ja die gewinner am kalten krieg
das brauchen wir nicht mehr entscheidend
was läuft und genau dafür bekommen wir
jetzt die quittung
deshalb sage ich ihnen es gibt nur einen
weg zur lösung wieder das völkerrecht
voll zur geltung zu bringen
und deshalb muss der westen als erstes
das völkerrecht in vollem umfang
einheiten hat der angst schulter
bestätigt dass er das völkerrecht
verletzt sein
macht gar keinen hehl draußen russland
wird sich nach dem konflikt ökonomisch
stärker nach asien orientieren
die usa werden verstärkt in europa
gerade auch in osteuropa auftreten
das ein erfolg für die usa 8 ticks ein
erfolg den obama gar nicht wollte so gab
das in meiner politik und die ju wird
völlig hilflos und sie ist der verlierer
weil die abhängigkeit von den usa noch
zunehmen wird
das kommt bei alledem heraus denken sie
mal darüber nach jetzt komme ich zu
europa ein warnsignal für europawahlen
haben die rechtsextremen und rechts
nationalen parteien erheblich gestärkt
da müssten wir doch eine
schlussfolgerungen daraus ziehen
frau bundeskanzlerin ihre falsche spar
statt aufbau politik gegenüber dem süden
europas
der abbau der demokratie der abbau der
sozialen gerechtigkeit die tatsache dass
eben die arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer in athen die ganze
bankenkrise zu bezahlen haben nicht die
millionäre
das alles hat auch zu diesem
wahlergebnis beigetragen
sie und wir alle haben eine
verpflichtung europa so friedlich so
demokratisch sozial gerecht und
ökologisch nachhaltig wie möglich zu
gestalten
damit dieses europa die menschen und vor
allem die jugend nicht versteckt sondern
endlich wieder anzieht und damit dieser
rechtsnationalen und rechtsextremen
parteien in ganz europa keine chance
dafür sind wir verantwortlich
mitverantwortung
ich sage ihnen einer
jugendarbeitslosigkeit von 60 prozent in
griechenland macht europa kaputt
ich habe es schon gesagt wir haben die
zahl der millionäre hat zugenommen
warum führen sie in der europäischen
union keine millionärssteuer ein und der
bundesfinanzminister
es gab doch mal die idee der
finanztransaktionssteuer gegen die
spekulation und spielereien an den
börsen wo bleibt sie eigentlich wann
tritt die eigentliche in kraft wird man
doch noch mal nachfragen dürfen
und nun komme ich zu schneiden und den
usa also der spiegel hat ja nun
veröffentlicht das die ausforschung
durch den geheimdienst der usa nse noch
viel größer als bisher angenommen waren
und das ist eine enge zusammenarbeit mit
dem bnd gang professor papier
der ehemalige präsident des
bundesverfassungsgerichts hat dazu
wörtlich folgendes gesagt der
datenaustausch mit ausländischen
diensten die ihre personenbezogenen
daten weitgehend unter methoden und in
einer art und weise erlangen die jenen
von mir kurz genannten mindeststandards
der deutschen unionsrechtlichen
grundrechte eindeutig nicht mögen ist
insoweit von verfassungs rechts wegen
ausgestellt das heißt mit anderen worten
der bnd hat sich grundgesetzwidrig
verhalten ich möchte wissen welche
konsequenzen sie daraus ziehen und
snowden hat bisher immer die wahrheit
gesagt
fußboden hat gesagt dass auch die
wirtschaftsdaten alle weitergereicht
wurden dass wirtschaftsspionage
auch das ist eine straftat und die
einzigen die wieder die interessen der
wirtschaft vertreten ist die linke und
die grünen in diesem falle sie nicht sie
das nicht das einfach
kommunikation sieben wochen die haben
mit obama und anderen gesprochen und sie
kommen ohne eines bei abkommen zurück
ich sage ihnen sie verhalten sich
diesbezüglich gegenüber der us
administration duckmäuser und sie
begründen wir das mit der freundschaft
und ich sage ihnen duckmäuser tun
erzählt verachtung aber keine
freundschaft wenn man eine freundschaft
will muss man sich als erstes respekt
erarbeiten
und ich sage ihnen auf wie man das
machen ich würde ich würde den
diplomaten ich würde dem präsidenten
obama an ihrer stelle sagen wenn sie
keines bei abkommen machen
dann werde ich die diplomaten der
britischen in der us botschaft die
spionage betreiben zur persona non grata
erklärt ich würde ihm sagen die nse baut
gerade ein riesengebäude in wiesbaden
das können die gerne fertigstellen aber
niemals eins hinter schicken war tag und
andere organisationen rein die was
nützliches machen im unterschied zu nse
die uns hier austauschen wollen weil ich
würde ihnen sagen wir können auch die
glp verhandlungen aussetzen
was glauben sie was ihnen das für ein
respekt einbringen würde wie die
diskutieren würden dass deutschland sich
die sache nicht mehr bieten lassen und
das entspricht ihren amtszeiten die mir
schaden von unserem volk abzuwenden
deshalb erwarte ich das laufen übrigens
zudem zieht die verhandlungen noch
einsatz
noch ein satz es geht noch dabei nicht
nur um das chlor was schon schlimm genug
wäre sondern es geht darum dass
investitionshemmnisse verboten werden
sollen und das muss man mal übersetzen
wenn ein amerikanisches unternehmen hier
seine wirtschaftstätigkeit beginnt und
später kommt eine vernünftigere
regierung macht mehr mitbestimmung macht
mehr wirtschaftsdemokratie vielleicht
sogar etwas höhere steuern können sie
sagen investitionshemmnis als wir
anfingen war das nicht so sie machen
politik und wirklich niemals dürfen das
verbot von investitionshemmnissen
vereinbart werden herr kollege
und dann muss ich ihn zum schluss
folgendes sagen
also ich hab das doch richtig verstanden
frau bundeskanzlerin der präsident obama
hat ihnen doch gesagt dass weder sie
noch herr gauck abgeschöpft das sind die
ausnahmen zu antworten dass ihr nicht zu
gesicht
das heißt der bundestagspräsident
professor lama sie werden nach wie vor
ab das heißt dass der unterschied zu
ihnen traf ich das mit fassung gegeben
das heißt dass auch der
bundesverfassungsgerichtspräsident
abgehört wird und alle anderen
bürgerinnen und bürger auch muss ich
ihnen folgendes erklären frau
bundeskanzlerin frau bundeskanzlerin
wenn sie mit ihrem ehemann professor
sauer telefonieren oder mit dem
vizekanzler gabriel oder mit
staatsminister altmaier oder mit ihrem
fraktionsvorsitzenden kauder die alle
abgehört werden dann hört man sie
zufällig mit wenn sie gas und reis
werden mit mir zu telefonieren erst
recht es gibt einen einzigen es gibt ein
die frau bundeskanzlerin dem sie alle
geheimnisse telefonisch und per e mail
an vertrauen dürfen dass ist der
bundespräsident aber aus irgendeinem
grunde glaube ich dass sie dazu gar
keine lust haben aber ich hoffe sie
verstehen dass wir zu ihrem etat nur mit
nein stimmen können
gregor gysi der oppositionsführer im
deutschen bundestag die linke hat ja
einen sitz mehr im parlament als die
grünen
und wenn man teile seiner rede so revue
passieren lässt dann muss man sagen
vielleicht ist der außenposition sich
oder gar nicht gerechtfertig gerade in
der frage ukraine hat er doch sicherlich
eine ganz andere meinung als blindes
gründen